Halo fans rejoice because we're getting  another free expansion sometime next  week this one is called infinities  armory and it marks the third free  update to come to halo 5 Guardians the  expansion will include a new arena map  called Riptide and a new war zone map  called urban the new update also adds  halo tues famous battle rifle as a  mythic weapon loadout requisition and  two new carbines one of which is fully  automatic and lastly the update adds a  new set of armor some weapon skins and  two new assassinations halo 5 guardians  launched in october for xbox one and  received an 8 on gamespot since it  released the game has received a free  content update every month are you still  playing halo 5 if not what you get back  into it be sure to let me know in the  comments below and for more details on  Infinity's armory head on over to Halo  Waypoint but if it's gaming news you're  after then you're already in the right  place